words are fun aren't they
here are two words you've probably never
seen before but which have some very
particular definitions
this first Ward autological is a term
denoting any word that describes itself
so for instance the word polysyllabic
itself being a polysyllabic word can be
classified as autological
and contradistinction a word such as
monosyllabic which is obviously not a
monosyllable word doesn't describe
itself
this latter type of word we term
heterological
other examples of autological words
include pronounceable
unhyphenated noun
Etc
their heterological counterparts would
be unpronounceable hyphenated adjective
and so on
words less related to language like dog
or chair obviously don't describe
themselves and so also fall under the
heterological category
thus for any given word x if x describes
itself it is autological
otherwise by definition X is
heterological
we now propose a simple statement for
your consideration
all words are either autological or not
autological I.E heterological
do you agree with this statement
think carefully because if you answered
yes you agree then great guess what you
just broke logic
this is dialect with
the grilling Nelson paradox
[Music]
can every word in a language always be
sorted into two distinct categories
it sure seems that way just start by
picking any arbitrary category then
whatever doesn't fit into that category
simply Place into an opposite leftovers
category
so if your category was words that begin
with S we can just find all the words in
our language that begin with S
ort those
then toss everything else into a does
not begin with S bin and call it a day
but something really funny happens if we
try this same tactic with the categories
of autological and heterological
specifically if we sort words into these
two categories we can do so with every
word in the English language except for
two the words autological and
heterological themselves
when we try to sort these words that is
when we ask our autological and
heterological themselves autological or
heterological words there arises a
paradox known as the growling Nelson
Paradox named for the German logicians
who founded it in the early 20th century
in a nutshell the Paradox goes like this
consider first the word heterological we
know that this word must be either
autological or heterological so let's
start by assuming it's autological well
then this implies that heterological is
a word which falls under its own
definition category meaning it's a word
which does not describe itself meaning
it's actually heterological contrary to
the starting assumption
so now instead we assume heterological
is heterological meaning it doesn't fall
under its own definition category I.E it
does not not describe itself
but of course this means it does
describe itself and is therefore
autological contrary to the starting
assumption
therefore heterological and from a
similar line of reasoning autological
are fundamentally unsortable wards
okay if you were able to follow that
congrats you're a natural logician
the rest of us however are sitting here
with our eyeballs crossed wondering what
the heck just happened
well it's actually pretty easy to see if
we just take things a little slower and
write out some simple sentences
let's start by noting that for any given
word X in the English language one of
the following two sentences must be true
one
the word X describes itself
2. the ward X does not describe itself
let's term this principle the fact that
a word either describes itself or
doesn't the principle of bivalency
next let's make the meaning of describes
itself a little more explicit by turning
these sentences into grammatical
formulas
let X be any arbitrary word and let y be
the definition of that word as it
applies to other words
then we have the word X is a word that y
the word X is not a word that y
this generalization allows us to
simplify the procedure for determining
whether any given word is autological or
heterological
for instance substituting the word
polysyllabic along with its definition
contains more than one syllable into the
formula yields the following two
sentences
the ward polysyllabic is a word that
contains more than one syllable
the word polysyllabic is not a ward that
contains more than one syllable
now here we can easily determine the
first sentence to be the true one
indicating the word polysyllabic is
autological
[Music]
If instead the second sentence for the
true one as in the case where we
substituted in monosyllabic then the
word would be heterological
we can also modify this formula slightly
in order to Encompass words that don't
describe other words such as in the case
chair
foreign
[Music]
we are now capable of sorting any given
word in the English language into its
respective autological or heterological
category
alright now let's tackle the Paradox by
inserting the words autological and
heterological themselves into these
formulas
let's start by assuming that the first
Formula the autological case is the
correct one
inserting in autological and
heterological
along with the respective definitions
yields the following sentences
the word autological is a word that
describes itself
the word heterological is a word that
does not describe itself
now note that the first sentence can be
Rewritten as the word autological is
autological
this checks out since it is consistent
with our initial assumption that
autological was autological
so far so good but now look at the
sentence the word heterological is a
word that does not describe itself
well a word that doesn't describe itself
is simply what defines the heterological
category meaning we can rewrite this
sentence as the word heterological is
heterological
this is bad because by starting out
under the assumption that heterological
was an autological word we managed to
prove in fact that heterological is
actually a heterological word
this blatant contradiction requires us
to conclude that our initial assumption
was wrong heterological cannot be sorted
into the autological category
well not a huge deal right let's just
sort heterological into the
heterological category
but here the exact same contradiction
arises according to the heterological
formula we can now form the sentence the
word heterological is not a word that
does not describe itself
again substituting in the definition for
heterological this becomes
the word heterological is not
heterological
or in other words the word heterological
is autological
a conclusion which again contradicts our
initial assumption
so no matter what category we attempt to
sort heterological into we always must
conclude that it belongs to the opposite
category resulting in a back and forth
infinite dance between classifications
similarly we find that the word
autological can be sorted into both
categories which is also a contradiction
this means the Ward's heterological and
autological are inherently unsortable
and so our assumption that every Ward
can be sorted into either autological or
heterological categories is falsified
but how can this be if a word isn't
autological then it must be not
autological meaning heterological
there isn't any other option
yet these Wards stubbornly refuse to
adhere to any such bivalent
classification
leaving us with a headache inducing
paradox
now the knee-jerk objection here is to
assert that the Ward's autological and
heterological are neither autological
nor heterological
but rather that there is some third
category that we should assign them to
but this objection is easily overcome
because we can always simply choose to
combine this third category with our
second category in order to ensure that
there are only ever two total categories
in accordance with the principle of
bivalency
that is if we start by saying there are
three categories autological
heterological and neither autological
nor heterological
we can combine the heterological and
neither autological nor heterological
categories into one category give it a
new name and simply repeat the Paradox
add infinitum
there's no way to escape by valent
classification which leaves us Reckoning
with a terrible truth logic is broken
ah
does all this leave you feeling like
you're being subject to some sleight of
hand some logical Ledger domain that's
obscuring the reality of what's actually
going on
well you're not alone in that feeling
indeed there's something awfully
specious about using logic to prove that
logic itself is broken
well with a language problem like this
it's pretty easy to shrug the whole
thing off as a sort of curious mental
exercise
Wards are essentially arbitrary and
meaningless at the end of the day anyway
right so who cares
well before you come to that conclusion
we haven't told you everything about
this Paradox yet the fact is this
Paradox is actually a famous problem
from mathematical set theory known as
Russell's paradox
it's just been translated from
mathematical terms into linguistic ones
moreover Russell's Paradox when modified
slightly and translated into a formal
self-referential logical language
becomes something known as girdle's
incompleteness theorem
but it doesn't stop there the Paradox
appears yet again in computability
theory under the name of the halting
problem
three major equally esoteric theorems
all rely on the exact vein of logic
presented here in order to demonstrate
their famous and widely heralded
conclusions
indeed if you could find even one tiny
flaw in the reasoning presented here
well you would strike a crack in an
edifice which has dominated mathematical
and philosophical thinking for well over
a century
this has been dialect
stay tuned